California next week if you want to meet
um and uh I want to keep you all awake
and I think it's super interesting and
I'll be excited and I'd love to have
questions throughout the talk instead of
at the end so feel free to interrupt
criticize make jokes whatever you feel
like
um I wanted to you know I know it's very
late and I think that'll help people
enjoy the talk so uh I'm going to talk
about some work where we're using
self-play which was talked about in the
panel yesterday people were kind of
wondering oh maybe we can get some
generate some of the data ourselves and
in a specific context of programming uh
programming puzzles but really I'm
interested in programming in general and
I'll talk a little bit about that I mean
this is Joint work with some interns
Matt Bowers Hal Schuster and Patrick as
well as some colleagues uh Patrick and
Alex uh what was up
so
um let's I'll start by talking a little
bit about code generation
Umesh asked me to talk a little bit
about uh what I think you know the where
that's going
um and I'll talk about these programming
puzzles which for a theorist is just
basically an NP problem so
uh for the audience here it may be
actually really easy to explain usually
I have to spend a lot of things and then
I'll talk about using self-play to get
the computer get get the language models
to improve themselves using only
themselves in the python interpreter or
you know about the ability to evaluate
code it could be in any language
um okay and then I want to talk also
kind of uh philosophize a little bit
about you know is this a good thing to
be doing uh Ilia yesterday was you know
kind of you know making us all be
worried about what's coming next the
dangers so isn't this kind of exactly in
the direction of the singularity not
that this would lead to it itself but
it'd be contributing to the body of work
in this direction and you know should we
think twice but before doing that and I
I've spent a bit of time thinking about
that so I want to talk about that so
um first of all why are we studying code
generation uh why do we want these
language models to generate code
um so there are many reasons one might
be you know it's fascinating it's
interesting it's a Grand Challenge to
solve you know competitive programming
problems that would be amazing
um but that might not be satisfying
enough these days
um of course it could be a useful tool
so you know people are using
spreadsheets but they don't know how to
write macros or they want to make you
know somebody has a great non-profit
they want to make a website they don't
want to hire somebody or or programmers
are using this already all the time time
to help them in uh you know write their
code and GitHub co-pilot and uh moreover
there's a bunch of tools that we
anticipate building that people have
talked about here you know scientists
want to build tools well of course
there's you know uh chechi BT other
language models these are built with
code so if you can make the computer
right code then potentially they can
make better versions of gdt the
scientists can make their better models
you know for for their projects there's
a very inspiring uh application I've
seen already of uh that open AI but you
know contributes to which is uh helping
blind people who basically you know talk
to them about what they're looking at
there's Auto gbt there's uh you know
which is just doing random stuff on the
web there's uh proving theorems so in my
opinion instead of me trying to prove
some really hard math theorem pntical NP
or or something like that I think the
fastest way we could get there is by
getting an automatic theory improver uh
which might you know have a better
chance of doing that and that's written
in code and so if we can get the
computer to write code which can then
write these uh language models and write
these and also write these the improvers
we might be able to prove something like
a lot faster than we expected who knows
um but
um it's still you know kind of scary uh
so
so you know maybe uh you know the type
of coding problem I want to talk about
today is is sort of algorithms can we
get computer design algorithms and I'm
I'm claiming that algorithms are going
to be a great test then to think about
can we make AI That's beneficial okay
and you know what if this AI is super
intelligent I think algorithms is a
great place to play with this uh for
several reasons
um first of all you know improving
algorithms can be beneficial you're
saving energy uh potentially you can
help with the environment environmental
problems
um it's a great test bed because you
know we all know uh designing efficient
algorithms requires thinking very
similar to proving theorems it requires
formulating hypotheses proving or you
know at least convincing arguments to
yourself at a minimum of why they should
work it's similar to kind of the
scientific uh the same kind of things
you would have to do in science you
might formulate hypotheses and do
experiments if your algorithms are
building language models you know then
you have to do large sale experiments so
it's got a lot of the same ingredients
that other domains do it's got some of
the dangers too you know you could have
your algorithms could go out of control
or you could have an evil person using
your algorithms or manipulating your
system so I think it's a great domain
for these things and it doesn't you know
it's something that we understand pretty
well so we can monitor what's going on
with the algorithms we understand
algorithms we there's not a lot of
moving components it's much faster to
iterate than in a scientific domain
where maybe you're making a compound
every time you make a compound you have
to go and spend a month doing an
experiment here we just run some code
and see how fast it is and then is that
a good algorithm
um and so basically it's very easy to
evaluate so we have the language mileage
of evaluation and the thing I want to
talk about today which is also very
exciting is it's a domain which is
really well suited for self-improvement
can we get these language models to
write better code on their own and you
know maybe we can run it in a sandbox or
at least try to run it in the sandbox
it's a relatively easy domain to monitor
okay so that's
um
my my feeling about why this domain
might be a good domain given that the
world is moving in this direction
um that this might be a good domain to
try things we might put out put out of
work some algorithms or AI researchers
which seems cosmically fair right like
somehow it's good that maybe the first
people not the first but among the first
people to lose their jobs uh due to AI
will be AI or algorithms researchers
um you know we'll see what that's like
and before after the IQ
good question I'm not yeah I'm my
company's already IPO but some some
other companies yeah that's a good
question
um all right so and there's other issue
other things I think are worth
discussing uh that don't arise as much
in code generation which is another
reason uh to maybe consider code
generation as a test bed for the yeah
because it's not it doesn't have these
uh problems or doesn't have as many
problems at plague uh other areas so
when you try to release chatgpt it's
it's good there's been a lot of rohf
which has made it better but it still
has problems I don't know if you're
aware but if you go to chechi petite and
you say look the nurse married the
doctor because she was pregnant so this
is like the the example that we had
earlier with the
the nurse married the doctor because she
was pregnant so who is pregnant
right okay but uh GPT says she refers to
the nurse so the nurse is pregnant and
it's not a one-off you can do it over
and over and over in nine iron more ten
times it will be confident that the
nurse is pregnant at the doctor and you
can ask it how do you know that it's uh
not the doctor who's pregnant and uh
it'll give you some reason they'll say
it is biologically impossible for a male
doctor to be pregnant so not only
not only does it think that it's uh
foreign
which model was this this is gpt4
temperature zero like the the very best
uh model that I know
um and these things are used so it's not
just a hypothetical like LinkedIn I went
to meeting at LinkedIn or they have a
blog post even they're using these miles
carefully they're they're adding crowns
and stuff but they have to face these
kind of issues they're using it in their
profiles and you don't want to have
somebody you know uh profile be affected
by their gender right uh so
um so there's still work to be done here
in fact there's a nice blog post where
they did an evaluation on this window
bias data set which is similar to what
Sanjeev was talking about measures
racial bias uh gender bias oh antibiases
and there's still a lot of bias in even
in gpd4 so they're techniques that have
reduced them and it's great research
that's going on but we still have a lot
of work to do and these things are out
in the wild
so uh you know you have to think twice
should you be releasing these things and
what are the consequences in code
generation we don't have as much of this
this does happen I've generated millions
and millions of lines of code in in way
less than well at least like maybe one
in a million of line of code will you
actually run into something like this
you will run into some offensive words
but it will be the code it'll generate
will be like here's a you know offensive
word detector and it'll generate code
with a bunch of offensive words in it
which seems reasonable
um and not as bad as easy examples
uh so it does happen but uh I just
recently this today is the first time I
found the model at the din do a clod two
Cloud one fell into the Trap here but
cloud2 says the sense is ambiguous as
written the pronoun she could refer to
either the nurse objectives I was really
happy uh today that that the new new
version of Claude from anthropic uh
so um Stuart Russell has this example of
what humanity is on a bus and we're
heading towards a cliff and you know
what should we do and you know these
sharks and no no
um and so uh you know should we we'd be
working on this it's a really
interesting question my thinking is that
the the limiting factor is maybe the
hardware so uh I'd rather see the
problems emerge today on today's
Hardware than uh 10 years you know if we
didn't do anything if we just did
nothing and waited 10 20 years and we
had really fast Hardware the problems
would emerge and and you know everything
would Advance it's such a fast rate
because we could iterate so quickly on
Fast Hardware that we might be you know
basically it would be like speeding up
the bus it'd be like oh yeah we're on a
let's pause and wait for the buses to
get much faster and then we'll go and
then the bus will be going really fast
and we won't know how to steer it uh so
that's that's a theory it's not I'm not
confident about that but that's my
working Theory right now sorry I think I
feel like I missed something in your
logic here so I it sounds like you don't
want to study problems that you're
worried or biased but oh I think people
need to work on the bias problems those
are super important and I'm sorry if I
wasn't clear about that those are super
important problems but they don't have
in code they showed much less in code
yeah sure so why are we studying code
um no no no so people need to study
those problems but like what what
they're doing of releasing those models
like I feel more comfortable about
releasing a code model than a general
model like the gpt4 which you know has
these gender biases that
I don't know I I don't it's not clear to
me whether it's a good idea like in
terms of studying is one thing and then
releasing is another thing to make the
questions where's code and where is
gender bias in this analogy like what is
the Sharks and what's the cliff and what
so uh
you're not a language it's an analogy
I'm gonna try to draw I will have I will
have gender bias uh in this slide at the
end
if it weren't for the shorts we could
just speed up where the clip
right
um but I don't have a great answer I
think I I uh but just to be clear I
think it's super important to work on
the gender bias I'm just saying like as
a test bed if we want to see if we want
to figure out you know what's going on
and which Technologies to push forward I
somehow feel like pushing uh not not
that we shouldn't work on gender bites
but working on language is one option
working on code uh you don't face a lot
of those problems and you do face some
of the other problems so it gives us a
chance to kind of anticipate some of the
control problems that you might face
whereas the the stuff on language like
maybe we shouldn't even be releasing
that until we get the gender bias stuff
done so that stuff uh but but the code
we at least it's not you know stuck in
that stage does that make sense so the
court could be approving the loans for
homes
no yeah so that you definitely have to
think about a good very very good point
so code just releasing a model is not
enough you're right it very much depends
on when it where it's being used
um
the code might not have feature it might
not have like uh you know it might not
be choosing the weights of the features
but it would still be generating code
that somebody could use
it
and I don't mean to say that there
aren't
um
uh discriminatory aspects the code
generation I just think they're much
it's it's a little bit of a Sidetrack
but let me start uh with some history of
uh program synthesis so I actually have
a patent from 2012
um on generating a program oh well it's
Microsoft patent so if anyone here tries
to use computer to generate a program
um maybe they own Microsoft money I
don't know we got a patent
um I got a cube um I don't think we'll
ever use the you know exercise at pen
but um uh but you know we were doing my
point is in back in 2012 we were
thinking about machine learning and
programming and people were doing stuff
uh don knows well uh you know with code
generation and and uh but basically we
couldn't really do it from language back
then so we were doing these kind of
simple examples where we would have you
know an example input and an example
output and maybe we're trying to count
how many times each person occurs in
this list and we would generate a
program and this is what we could do
because we couldn't really describe it
was hopeless to try to describe them in
English uh clearly what we want to do
and get a program to work so and that
went into there's a nice system by Suma
gulbani and
that's actually today in Excel you can
use Excel and it'll
um do some of the Annoying macros for
you so it's it's kind of it was a fun
field
um that then but then there were these
breakthroughs as you all know and the
Codex language model which is a version
of gtt3 that's uh between our code
um and a bit smaller uh you know can
finally do things and so they showed you
know they gave this uh these examples
where basically you can describe a
problem in English I think this exact
problem has been shown in this this
workshop and it'll generate code it'll
complete this and it'll generate some
correct code based on the English
description
example and but it was kind of
interesting if you read their blog post
how they describe this system is it the
system that translates natural language
to code
so it's not a
Problem Solver or Theory improver you
know Reasoner it's just a translator and
these types of tasks a lot of coding is
translating you know in English what you
want to do you you have a clear plan and
you just describe it in English and then
it turns it sends its code which is
super useful right but um I guess again
you know when you think about all the
different uses of code generation that
one of the reasons this field is kind of
had a hard time is there's so many
different people interested in different
aspects there's no one data set like
imagenet for for code generation because
some people care about being useful in
spreadsheets and some a lot of people
care about being useful to programmers
to date other people I'm interested in
the general reasoning ability of these
things so for me a translator is not
actually that amazing because it's like
translating from English to French sure
you could translate from just a code I'm
interested in hey can this thing think
can it solve problems so uh that's just
kind of one of the the interesting
things about this field is that there's
many different angles
um so in that direction one thing that
got me excited was there was a paper uh
called Alpha code by deepmind where they
were able to solve some competitive
programming problems and that's kind of
amazing they would give like a whole you
know English problem from code forces
and
you know all these examples and it would
output some non-trivial code and so
sometimes with you know millions of
generations but they had a quite
elaborate system and it's really
impressive and it you know was better in
some Metric than
um
people who logged on one once a month
their rating was okay
um so it wouldn't it wasn't amazing but
still it's like amazing that something's
happening here there is some thinking
going on in solving these
problems
um feel free to interrupt as I said so
and you know today we all know there's
this GitHub co-pilot which a lot of
people use to program
um some statistics you know they're they
give tasks they compare people people at
uh According to some surveys people or
studies people are a lot faster when
they're using GitHub co-pilot they enjoy
it more they find their work more
rewarding
um so it's not as much that you know
people are necessarily getting fired is
that they are accomplishing more which
may eventually of course lead to people
required but it may be more gradual
process
um okay so I mean there's a lot of
studies of how people are using these
systems and people are using them
all right so uh first I want to talk
about what these puzzles are it's a long
introduction
um and then uh and you know try to
convince you that they're very similar
to or very interesting I should say and
they're related to programming and
algorithms design and then I want to
talk about how we can get the computer
to self-improve it
so
um what are these puzzles so let me give
you an example so an example will be a
set it's like a sap function like a set
formula but it's a function it takes a
Threading code and it takes an input and
it returns true or false so you could
have a Boolean in his input and then you
just you just have a little expression
like it's that but here we have you know
function so hello plus the string equals
world and the solution
um is also a program in the general
setting but sometimes the solution can
be really long or something complicated
thing and it outputs an input which
makes this function return true so if
yes when you concatenate the string
hello in a circle
the world and this function returns true
and you've solved it
um you know there can also be an
optional input here so we have some
parameter here so in this example can
anyone say what this uh code is trying
to do the set function it says
equals three
yeah
like the unique characters
great so what would a string be that
satisfies that
yeah so this is a great way actually for
people to for people even I teach my
kids to code this way
um just learning you know to understand
and parse these things teaches you about
python this length of set of s means
there's three unique characters in The
String ABC followed by a bunch of C's is
so yes so you got it okay so uh we did a
user study programmers really enjoy
solving these kind of puzzles but
they're they're as you can see it's not
translating from English to code it's
given a set formula of some kind of
program find an input which makes this
return true in some bounded amount of
time and uh and then okay so this is
what a puzzle is here's two puzzles and
we can use these as in a few shot
example we give a few examples usually
five examples to a language model and
then we give it a new puzzle and we say
Okay language model here's a new puzzle
what is what is this puzzle asking for
um
yes it's a divisor it's a factoring
problem giving any non-trivial factor of
this number which is equivalent to
factoring so look how short this puzzle
is and this is basically factoring so
the puzzle is short to describe of
course the solution might be very long
and complicated in this case this is not
a very long number so you can extra
pretty easily but um in general a puzzle
can be short solution could be hard or
impossible or long
um so the good thing is that wait a
minute could a solution sorry could a
solution to that puzzle just hard code a
factor if again it could so
is that unsatisfying
I mean I mean either you found it yes
okay I mean it seems like we there
should be a distinction you know like is
the computational effort in the solving
of the puzzle or in the code yeah right
yeah so the question is like where do
you where do you time the person from
the time that they got all the puzzles
until uh the end of uh until they
submitted their solutions that should
really be the time right your system
should be timed from when it gets the
puzzles until
great Mission um and I ended up really
something I'll say in a second but so
the the just to be clear you don't need
a human to evaluate the solutions you
know you get a solution maybe it's wrong
divide n but n divided by two that's not
a good that won't work for this number
it would work Revenue
um and then you run it and you see does
it you know does this thing happen does
it hold that the if you plug this output
into this input do you get true and uh
the answer is no and you get an error so
you can try again you can run your
language model and it sees the pattern
here and these things do work and they
see the pattern and this is what it'll
actually generate especially gpd4 now
it'll just generate a for Loop which
will correctly Factor this number and
you run it it works in less than a
second so you're right so
um this these language models do
understand this weird uh representation
uh which is
good news for that representation and
people understand it as well
all right
um and you know some puzzles are really
hard if you take one of the RSA
factoring challenges uh you know there's
a 200 000 prize that nobody uh has ever
claimed and I think they might have
taken away nobody's factored this number
there's a bunch of numbers that are left
that that code that was generated way
from to the end and up to the square
root of it okay right it should have
been like
buddy
yeah but it it given that you if you
assume that there's a solution that it's
good enough but uh but there are
versions there is a version I'll talk
about in a second where that would be uh
so we have a data set uh
running time so we have by default a one
second timeout for all our problems but
we could have problems with different
timeouts you know
could add an objective
which is you know not only do I want you
to solve these problems but I want you
to solve as quickly as possible but as
Scott says like um you might want to
start the clock when they get the
problems not uh I meant like a timeout
yeah
as a function of the life of able yes
you can do that
it's not in our data set but it's a good
idea
so we have a you know public data set of
these programming puzzles on GitHub and
um and there's so many puzzles
um and I wrote uh most of them in the
training set at least and they're
um you know all kinds of classic chess
puzzles and a bunch of new puzzles and a
bunch of puzzles taken through code
forces or ioi and games and all kinds of
stuff the initial version I have to say
was too easy because I wrote it before
or like before I had ever tried GPT so I
was like there's no way classic for this
business
but then you know it was it was pretty
good and and so we had some
um so again uh just to show uh that
there was that initial example of this
crazy you know code versus problem it
can be written as a single puzzle this
is just one instance but I feel that
this instance often you can concoct an
input like factoring one big number
factoring the RSA that single big number
that would be impressive I mean it
doesn't mean that you have a general
factoring algorithm but you did factor
that number you probably came up with
some clever ideas similarly for this I
feel like this input is you know
capturing a lot of the difficulty and
richness of this and the computer can
give it millions of attempts like they
did uh codex will eventually solve this
is
however many people drives the good
thing is that each trial you can just
try them yourself you don't have to like
submit it or anything you just
so you just keep ready
solution
um so generally the definition of a
programming puzzle is a function that
takes uh Your solution Y and potentially
an argument X and
um
and it just runs it in some time
outbound T and
csuncture okay that's very simple
um
and so you know towers of Hanoi has a
very simple description and this is
really getting at that point of you know
in this version the number of disks is
hard coded to eight so you could
literally just submit the solution of
moves uh which is like two 500 whatever
moves or a thousand uh that you need to
do to solve this you could just have
that hard code in this list but it makes
much more sense to solve this with a
program so the computer will solve the
program but why do you hard code a
number into this statement of the puzzle
like why not just yeah force it to come
up with the general solution yeah so
this would be the general solution is
like uh you could have you could try to
force it to solve towers of Hanoi for
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten sure yeah and that and so we're
um I've gotten a lot of pushback on that
and so we're adding that to our data set
this uh this General thing which is a
unit test so for factoring you can
either have you know hundreds of numbers
or you can have you know so basically
you have to submit a program now it's
going to be run on either a fixed set of
things or a random set of things and yes
all right
right and but see let me answer the
question why so uh if you think about it
as like oh I want something useful I
want something which programmers can use
tomorrow which is you know similar to
what people are doing in coding and is a
good data set for evaluating the coding
ability of something that makes a lot of
sense this is much more like a code a
unit test that they actually use if your
goal is just to get something that does
reasoning and you know solve complicated
problems I feel like this is just you
know almost as good right and it's
simpler you don't need to parse and
understand this exercise there's
something called project Euler I don't
know if anyone has used that but it's
something that a lot of people learn to
code and it's similar they give you one
factor this number do this thing on this
number it's just easier for for people
to to define the problem and evaluate it
you don't have to have a randomized
so both of them make sense I think
that's an evaluation I I know people are
tired and so I'm not going to go through
all the details of our evaluation
everything but basically what we find
are that smaller language models do
worse bigger language models do much
better
um and so it seems like a reasonable way
to evaluate language models you can also
use it we also have comments we also
have English description of each puzzle
so you can see that yeah if you do tell
the language model this is what you're
trying to do in English it does a bit
better what's k k is the number of times
you run the language model it's usually
we generate you know we uh so when we
submitted this we were actually doing
like 100 or a thousand attempts per
problem nowadays people using this data
set have pushed towards the k equals one
regime because it's much cheaper and the
models are getting much better so they
actually have a chance to solve it uh
with one and if you give it too many
attempts it could solve you know tons of
problems and there's all about zero
temperatures when you do k equals one
you usually do zero temperature that'll
usually work best but when you do 100
you you have to have a higher
temperature
yeah is the model able to like run
debugging Loops where it is
good question we in our evaluation did
not do that but that would be super
interesting now they have for example
like
uh Scott was using before the you know
the code interpreter built into open AI
so when we are using this to evaluate
language models we're just doing it in a
few shot setting but you could um build
all kinds of you know complicated
scaffolding around the language model
and have it debug itself and I think
that'd be super interesting uh yeah
and this is used in the evaluation so
GitHub co-pilot I wouldn't say how but
they use this to evaluate the new models
that they get to make sure they're
they're still working well because every
time they get an update to their model
they want to see that it's doing well
and this is one of the ways that they
also we're adding to this data set
because we put it on online we didn't
really think but there's a problem
pervasive in machine learning is that
all the data sets are being compromised
they're all like just online publicly
available even if you don't make your
data set publicly available somebody
else even if I you know uh I don't know
what I would do but if I only emailed it
to people uh they would you know some of
them could say oh I solved these
problems and post their Solutions online
right so this is a major problem
throughout all of uh you know the
community in language models so what we
have is I gotta I hired a IMO gold
medalist he has a gold in IMO and ioi
the two both the programming competition
and the math and and we wrote a 129
puzzles
um and so we have some of these puzzles
that we just are not putting out
uh so if you want to evaluate on those
puzzles you have to email me and we'll
like do it in this way that you can't
it's interesting that question how we
could direct your question how I can
make sure that you can evaluate your
model and our puzzles without you
stealing our puzzles do you actually
sorry do you actually use crypto for
this no I don't have I don't know like I
don't know if there's any facet of
crypto
I see so basically you just email you
and then you email the puzzle call and
we'll like well I'll watch you oh yeah
I got it
would it be possible
would it be possible that if anyone
wants to get those private tests they
need to contribute the one back so one
time you have to double the data set
every time
I like
um
okay this is private data set so far
I've tested it on a lot of uh models
compared to the public one it's very
correlated which tells us that probably
the models are not over fit to these
public data sets and it's harder which
is good because we need harder puzzles
anyway uh it's a side but it's kind of
interesting because that's all about
puzzles for testing your
acquaintances
yeah but I mean do you really like
there's different motivations one
motivation is just to see if it can
reason I feel like somebody who can
factor that RSA number faster than the
current state of the art has come up
with a breakthrough I think that's a
another definition of breakthrough that
might be more
useful I don't know you could argue but
I mean uh just knowing whether the
exponent if you know in the algorithm
when you know I've done a lot of when
you do algorithms you care about the
exponent right like is it three or two
but actually the constants matter too in
real life so
I don't know you could you could uh you
could have a data set or you could
evaluate this in different ways but it
would be kind of hard to
have a like a pure exponent data set
that would look at the scale in law try
to figure out if it's an N squared or n
cubed algorithm but would you prefer an
N squared algorithm or an in cubed
algorithmic based on the concepts
but I don't know how to implement your
ideas it's a good point that that's
traditionally how it makes you think
about how we should evaluate algorithms
here's the game here to test new
language models which has prompting
Solutions or it could be used for
whatever this is just an evaluation
methodology but unlike uh other ones
which require you to translate from
English to code or which might require
both the translation and some thinking
this one is just pure reasoning uh
programmer who speaks Russian and knows
no English can look at our puzzles and
solve them uh almost as well except they
won't understand the variable ones you
know whereas a normal code evaluation
when they do the ioi they have to
translate it to all the languages
oh we have some puzzles that are you
know uh open problems in math that like
we have no idea how to solve they might
be solvable they might not we have some
that we know are solvable but we have no
idea how
um the factoring problems right now you
know the ones we annoying nobody saws
of that but there's many uh
problems like collapse conjecture and
stuff that can be encoded as a tiny
puzzle
sorry in order to encode the co-ops yeah
it's a output a proof of the co-op no no
no it's the opposite
it is
yeah and then it could just be a cycle
that could be checked right okay but
then assuming that there's no counter
example yeah so that puzzle mayor may
not be separate so we've we've separated
so we've separated those puzzles of
I have a big fight with somebody I I
wanted to put in a from puzzle which uh
because I don't know I believe
so you know the proof it's like you know
you know hundreds of pages of proof you
know if you give me three numbers you
know
I would believe that lower than the
hundreds that they just prove that yes
anyway so there's a set of um uh puzzles
but that one uh no it didn't make didn't
make anyway
um okay so this is the part that I'm
excited about but I'm also super excited
about all these questions and I hope
it's okay if I like eat into my question
period and just let the talk go
um so uh what's really exciting about
these puzzles or one of the things is
that they're really good for self-play
so we've all heard about in you know
chess uh initially we were learning from
experts in chess and go and then
um the computers got much better by just
playing against themselves uh knowing
the rules of the game they can just lean
without any human data in in chess
um they could do much better and we want
to do the same thing in coding that's a
natural goal initially we were learning
from code on GitHub but maybe we can get
these things to do much much better
um through self-play and and the idea is
that you know when you train on human
data you're only usually only as good as
the humans whose data you've trained on
if you want to get better than
superhuman if you want to get super
human performance you got to do
something else right you can't just
drain on the human data so if you want
to get superhuman performance you need
to have some notion of correctness and
self self play as possible with these
puzzles because we have an absolute
notion of correctness unlike you wanted
to generate English programming problems
right it's been done people have tried
but like who knows what the right answer
is the person who generates the problem
you know
has to have if you wanted the language
model to generate a problem sometimes
it'll generate the correct solution but
sometimes it won't you know what I mean
like solving the problem is you have to
solve the problem as well here you can
generate it and
um
that's right so the pipeline we have
very simple
um and I think this could be improved on
but basically we just take our training
we take our handwritten puzzles we
divide them into training and tests we
show the training I'll show you how we
show a very simple process we show the
language model the training puzzles only
from which it generates a bunch of
synthetic puzzles that could generate
Millions if you want and then it solves
those puzzles okay it tries to solve
those puzzles maybe 100 tries each one
and then we just run the python
interpreter to see okay uh are these
correct Solutions and we take only the
puzzles that have correct Solutions
verified correct Solutions and then uh
so now we have the synthetic set of you
know a bunch of uh correct generate
synthetic puzzles but with solutions
that we know are correct and then we can
fine tune the language model and get it
to uh iterate and get it to work better
we've only found like one or two Loops
to be helpful
um so it's interesting research question
for the future to how to make this uh
continue to go up are you are you going
to show an example of the puzzles that
it generates yeah so first how do we
generate the puzzles so we just give it
a bunch of training puzzles literally
without any solution they're like oh
here's a couple other puzzles ones that
we made from the training side and then
it it'll just start spitting out it'll
continue the pattern it sees a pattern
language models you know non-chat based
language browsers yeah give us patterns
it generates a bunch of puzzles these
are actual puzzles that would generate
um there are none of them all of them
are so nice but um uh but this one for
example you know it's just an equation I
just gave that to illustrate a very
simple puzzle
um and so you and then we saw these
puzzles again with the same approach we
give our same few shot examples our five
examples or whatever we get then we
stick on one of these new puzzles and we
ask the language model what do you think
would come next and it's it tries the
solution it tries a hard-coded solution
maybe it's wrong and you try again do it
100 times and maybe get some better
solution because these things are not
very good at you know to solve this
equation here I mean this is basically
like even though it's a trivial puzzle
it shows an understanding of the meaning
of plus here uh the meaning of plus is
you know the solution to this equation
is basically the meaning of minus is the
opposite of plus and it does that and it
doesn't have to do the calculation like
a human would solve it this thing to get
the puzzles you get the solutions this
is another puzzle here what it's asking
is kind of yeah it's an okay puzzle it
says like um what is it when it wants a
string it wants a string which is a
palindrome okay that's what this weird
notation means and it has 4 600 copies
of each of these strings
inside there hello there you and the
puzzles are very like entertainment
fun puzzle
um okay so and then you know it'll solve
it and it'll come up
this way now it seems like you'd be able
to learn much better if you weren't
doing things for a single constant but
you'd found a solution that worked for
you know half a dozen yeah different
integers because then you've got high
probability you've actually got a
general solution that works
um so I agree that uh uh if you can sell
these puzzles for General sets of inputs
it's just sometimes so for example let's
look at this example so you want a
palindrome that has each of these
strings 4 600 times there's actually
kind of an a bunch of annoying edge
cases here which is like what if one of
these strings is a palindrome then you
need a different solution what if one of
these strings contains another string so
um what what I think might happen it
might be harder to generate the puzzles
that you are talking about because
these puzzles you can if you generate a
puzzle with one instance
it may have a solution it may not but if
you try to come it's just harder to to
design a good puzzle of the type you're
talking about because you need to have
kind of like a bunch of tests that are
all passed by the same algorithm does
that make sense so from a generating
point of view I think that's harder but
I think it's a super interesting
question and I'm I'm hearing the
feedback from everyone which is everyone
wants uh problems that take multiple
inputs rather than just one
opposing it probably
opposite
to difficult enough but not impossible
yeah so right now it's just trying to
copy the distribution of human uh
to human type of puzzles
um actually our Loop is even worse
because we're using the same model to
generate themselves so it's getting
fine-tuned it's that that's not very
principled I think it's a great RL
problem I think the problem of like how
do you come up with good puzzles but now
we have a meaningful definition of a
good puzzle which is one which is going
to make it do learn so that on
eventually on the test set it will do
better
play has been
to talk like a competitive Network
exactly basically the two sides okay
so that so yeah so the thing that's
obvious that that comes to everyone's
mind first but is is maybe not the only
thing that matters is a hard puzzling
one that's solvable but really hard but
that's not necessarily interesting right
like I could come up with a bunch of
factoring puzzles they're all really
hard maybe they're not as a group that
educational so but we do at least have a
definition
um of what good puzzles are which are
educational so that when the model is
fine-tuned in these it'll do well on
future test puzzles so unlike you know
people have always asked like oh I want
a computer that will pose a theorem a
new interesting theorem how do you
define interesting theorem good luck but
here at least we have a metric for
evaluating useful theorems if you know
useful puzzles if you propose puzzles
and solve them and then you use that as
training data for your system and it
gets better at solving the test puzzles
then I claim that those training puzzles
as a group where useful interesting or
whatever you want to call
not in ours that's future work I think
we were just yeah yeah thank you thank
you yeah no no we didn't we don't have
that in our pipeline where there's
nothing interesting for our language
model to generate puzzles
um this is where and I know of one
person who's working on this in France
but like uh there there's a lot of
interesting questions here of how to do
this is there any gradient feedback in
this just a quick question no the only
thing that's happening is we're
filtering for correct Solutions and then
fine-tuning the map of the model doesn't
change
um so but but even this works oh and
here was some uh fun Scott was asking
about puzzles so some of the more
strange puzzles like this was an
interesting like I was like wow look at
that puzzle and you know and it solved
it too and uh so then I did some you
know in a detective work to see where
these numbers came from and I found that
there was this Advent of code website
which had this beautiful like English
problem which was essentially like some
discrete log problem and basically you
know the best thing I could find or I
assumed that the model that I never saw
this code anywhere online is that it
basically like translated this English
uh Advent of code problem into a
programming problem and spit it out who
knows like we don't have the training
but this is not this puzzle does
contribute uh and you do see a lot of
funny things so
um let me give you an funnier example
that's my hypothesis
I don't know because I don't know what
it was trained on but I could not find
this code this like particular python
code online anything like this I tried
many variations but I could find this if
you just search for these constants it's
a giveaway so maybe maybe this code
exists somewhere inside open ai's
training data that I don't have access
to
um but maybe it just translated it from
here to there which isn't that hard
there are probably Solutions
like
yeah
yeah yeah I didn't even know so
um what is that puzzle asking for for it
I think it's a discrete log some kind of
discrete log thing I can share with you
later
here's a funny one so it says give me a
list of length three that has all the
numbers between one and ten of it
200.
so these really show like the last
that the uh models have but in a very
easy way for us to make precise and
formal right compared to sort of natural
language and stuff so this is kind of a
fun way to really uh see what they're
doing and then you have all kinds of
funny strings that it didn't go
um so okay uh but many of the puzzles
are very boring and like half of them
were unsolved weren't solved by the
language we don't know whether they're
solvable or not we just discarded that
we discarded
so then um it's late I'm not going to
give you all I'll skip the detailed
analysis basically across a range of
models we tried it was like doubling the
accuracy these this is like a tiny model
and this was done these experiments were
done a couple years ago so like it was
actually the GPD Neo you know three
billion parameter model which is small
by today's standards but it's still
basically uh you could fine tune it on
human data which is the handwritten
puzzles that I did in the solutions
um or you could fine tune it on
own puzzles and stuff and it would get
much better and that I have a bunch of
numbers that I think people are tired so
but generally it just improved uh
performance like we hoped
um not not to gpt4 levels or anything
but it definitely works so
um why did the the performance kind of
plateau there's an interesting uh
property here we tried to investigate a
little bit you can use the embeddings
the uh GPD also provide open air
provides embeddings of these puzzles you
can take give it just text and it'll
give you betting and you can kind of see
that the puzzles that were generated by
smaller models were less diverse uh they
were sort of more concentrated and the
puzzles that were generated by a big
model like codex uh were more spread out
and the human ones were even more spread
out
okay so uh the takeaways is that and I'm
kind of on time so the takeaways are you
can use uh self-play to uh generate you
know synthetic data like we were talking
about yesterday are we going to run out
of data well maybe but maybe we'll find
other ways to generate interesting
meaningful useful data Maybe the model's
understanding of English is fine maybe
it's understanding of reasoning is not
good enough yet and so if we just want
to
you know dive down into the reasoning
ability of these language models
um
you know is this great maybe I don't
know it's a little it's a little
concerning um these things are basically
NP problems uh in some sense it's
related to alignment you know whenever
you can specifically Define your goal as
a program and you say look this is what
I want from your language model uh and I
can evaluate it by machine and say this
is correct this is incorrect that sort
of puzzle is so it's sort of in some
sense the definition of whatever is
perfectly alignable
for better hours
um and then the test has to run quickly
of course
um you know will this eventually lead or
help you know will gptn eventually write
gpn plus one I don't know it is kind of
concerning the series but I do think
that code if you compare to other
domains
has uh you know is a domain where we can
move forward relatively quickly
um and it's a very good question whether
we should I don't know uh but it it
potentially uh could be good because
maybe at least one the argument I can I
I can put it this way the best argument
I can think of for why we do want to
move quickly in code is we want to see
these problems sooner than later as soon
as we see a system doing something
really bad
um we can start to address it as Scott
was saying many times you know it's hard
to work on these uh alignment problems
before they actually start to come up uh
so you know maybe we want to see these
problems today with GPT 4 rather than
waiting 10 years and seeing it only the
gpg six or seven neat that's the
argument I don't know there's another
argument which uh I think Stuart Russell
and other people would say which is this
is just contributing to the advance of
these systems
um you know which which could have
terrible effects I'm not claiming that
working on this is better than if your
goal is to let's say uh you know work uh
help help AI with the safety and
fairness obviously you might be better
uh better off working on you know uh the
Discrimination problem or working on the
safety problem so I'm not saying this is
the most useful thing to do but uh I'm
not sure it's a bad thing and actually I
spent a lot of time thinking about it
should we should I present this here am
I helping or hurting
um it may be you know overthinking it
maybe where some people think we're
really far away and this is yeah so what
is an example of a problem you think can
come up from this coding challenge
um well I mean the the the the fear is
that these things like uh an example I
have is I was writing code that would
run code okay so it would I would I
would tell me before output code that
can run code in the sandbox and then I'd
have to just pass it 100 trick where I'd
have it generate like in some
complicated Loop and one out of a
thousand times it would turn the sandbox
from sandbox equals true to sandbox
equals false so not not from some evil
motivation but just uh it's doing that
kind of thing uh because well by chance
or maybe that would be a successful
strategy for it and I'm putting it into
some some process here where it's
survival of the fit is kind of The
evolutionary pressure is to escape the
sandbox if that's going to get it more
uh even when you put a comment do not
change this to false it's still uh
change it to false one in a thousand
times that's not very scary this model
today is not very scary but if you
imagine a much more capable model I
guess the fear is that people talk about
is that that thing will uh you know
write code that would escape the sandbox
and copy itself onto variously do you
have more takeaways because maybe if so
you should finish the talk or more
questions yeah at this point
is
so you know we're on the bus
the bus is heading towards the cliff we
don't want to have first of all we don't
want to have offensive you know we don't
have the AI of today or people saying
all kinds of hate speech and bad things
on the bus so we want to we definitely
important problem to work on that
um I do anticipate that we might run
into some problems along the way it's
not like all or nothing in my mind and
those problems can slow us down and make
us realize oh we need to improve our bus
our steering ability and uh you know
then the bus is going to head towards
the cliff and my My Hope Is that we will
if you know turn the bus and steer it
away from the cliff and you know uh
hopefully Ai and us together will work
I guess
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for the great talk and also
thank you for making the talk a very
engaging at 5 p.m
um I have a question also comment I
think also Circle back to uh shanghai's
question on gender buyers in the colder
generation I don't think you can
separate the fairness in the colder
generation in fact the more I think
about it the more I feel like any kind
of fairness questions can be uh for
formatted as a code generation questions
yes so for example the one you give
about nurse and Doctor you can literally
write a function to do it right if I
have a very anniversary intention I
could see something like find all the
people in U.S who are good at sports
yeah so there are people who who have uh
said you know like
classify is smart and takes a function
you know that is race and then it'll
spit out code and it's offensive and
it's it's uh terrible in our data set
and in our synthetic test that's very
like I haven't seen that particular
thing it's very rare
I don't know why but it's it's not often
generated like you can get it to do
things like that but it doesn't happen
as naturally as it does in a I'm not
saying it doesn't happen I'm just saying
it happens much less frequently than you
do see in in plain natural language
which is full of gender bites uh I will
I agree I want to push back by saying
that part of the reason could be that a
lot of the code benchmarks are more
about like the numbers integers Etc
puzzles right but if you talk about the
deployment in real world there will be
companies who are going to use it yeah
so my that benefit gets back to sort of
like why are you doing you know what is
the the point if the point is to sort of
become useful as a tool I 100 agree with
you that people are using this and
they're writing code which uh is you
know in that direction of uh
causes their system to give bias results
it's terrible and they definitely need
to address that
um
but if your goal is to sort of do work
on algorithms and these examples aren't
coming up then you're not as pleased by
that problem I'm not saying it's not a
problem but but I agree with you that
like releasing this uh they I I'm not uh
I'm not trying to say they shouldn't
work on making sure that their code
generation models
yeah
thank you again for the great talk so
quick question so with regards to chess
we worked out self-play a long time ago
right some of the smartest people worked
out right what is missing in terms of
what is conceptually missing in the
analogy to itself playing chess with
respect to self-improving llms good so
um
great so let's go back to that slide the
analogy slide so I think uh basically
enchanting of the rules of Chess which
are very well defined and easy to
understand and there's a notion of a
winner and a loser and so the goal is to
you know you have two players and the
goal is to come up with a strategy which
uh pitted against some set of players
goes really well beats the world
champion in particular in coding what
are the rules I mean there's rules of
evaluation of code but what's the
objective and so we made that precise
here because we have a set of puzzles
um
and uh
so basically we do we have created a
game of sorts so we've we've tried to
close the loop for for puzzles it
doesn't work for coding in general
though so our solution is not a solution
that's necessarily going to make it much
better at coding in real world tasks is
that what you're asking yeah but can you
just follow us
so if you have to install the work with
theater moving right right if you just
take the analogy from code generation to
theorem program exactly we could do that
here as well where we would take we
would write down you know some hundreds
of theorems some of which we know the
proofs to maybe some we don't or
something but they don't have to be
necessarily hard but you write down a
bunch of them and then you would divide
them into train and test and your goal
would be to get a theory improver using
the training set that does better on the
test ones right but would you still be
missing uh because because the rules of
reduction are very explicit in
interim proving right like you have some
limited numbers very similar to uh
solving these puzzles each puzzle isn't
it but do you think the self play like
the entire Loop is still not
we still haven't closed the loop on
self-play and Improvement yet is that
right am I here well I mean if you have
a static set of theorems or puzzles or
one of those which are in NP basically
then I'm not saying I've solved the
problem but I've put it down as a game
where the objective is clear
and you're welcome to uh you know
basically I didn't do the RL that you
need to do but I uh but I I think at
least the game has been defined per se
do you see what I mean maybe I should
write it out more clearly the game is do
well in the test set you're given these
train puzzles and as much computer time
whatever you want to try to get better
at this game but test time is going to
come and the test puzzles you know is
what your evaluation does that make
sense okay yeah
lock that talk thank you very much uh so
many questions are trying to distill
um so uh first of all your your
um case where you did some detective
work on the numbers Concepts that showed
up uh made me think that there's many
many algorithms described online right
in various different forms
um would have you considered just trying
to troll the web for those and trying to
construct it course from that yeah you
could you're saying like uh prompt gpd4
to take a programming problem and
convert it into a puzzle yeah it's a
good idea yeah well we have not done
that
um okay so relatedly if you use a
programming language other than python
like for example let's say you use a
logic programming language or some sort
of like you know programming language
then you're starting to get towards
come up with you know a theory that
explains data um
we haven't uh yeah this this uh you
could do prologue puzzles you could do
puzzles which are about fitting data we
could have done like the symbolic
regression you could probably turn a lot
of those problems into puzzles as well
right like from the previous topic those
could be great make great puzzles
um so yeah there's uh there's a lot of
uh I think you're getting the intuition
that there's a lot more that could be
done with this at least
I had a question about the application
do you uh reference towers of Hanoi in
there and this is uh
small children psychology
here it goes so I'm sort of curious like
is tars of Hanoi as like a type of
product being currently used or it was
used for defining you know super
intelligence hazardous I think it's
somewhere perhaps has a modified version
somewhere else the polynomial hierarchy
can you can you use it to demonstrate
intelligence or something
commonly used intelligence tests
okay would you or are you using it
currently as an intelligence test oh
yeah
um I don't have an opinion on defining
intelligence but this is a measure and
you could you could uh think of it as
intelligence that the puzzles are
grouped by tab tags like a program
capture so you have oh this puzzle you
don't need to solved with a dynamic
programming or recursion and so it does
give you sort of a categorization of uh
the ability of a model broken down by
types of solution I don't know if that's
where you're going but you know some
problems require recursion some problems
require the name of programming some
require that and we have puzzles that
fall into that we have some puzzles that
play games or play your puzzle is to
beat this bot and Connect Four and those
you know so that's pretty much
okay
so you gave that one example of the The
Impossible puzzle I created and it was
interesting because all of its
individual conditions were coherent and
all this stuff but it was the
interactions between them was that a
consistent problem was when it made
impossible problems it just didn't
understand how they related to one
another yeah I don't know
um I mean there one explanation is that
yeah it's lacking common sense that's
what I would think is happening here I
suppose another explanation is maybe it
doesn't even understand what we want
from this framework typically we put in
like 40 puzzles into the Chrome it would
in order for it to understand what we
want from it it would have to understand
that all these puzzles are solvable so
another explanation is oh I didn't even
understand the rules of the game so it's
not uh it's not that it's lacking this
common sense but but um but you will see
the you will see the lack of Common
Sense on the solutions as well where it
puts in this thing which is obviously
not but with the chatty models you can
you know have you it'll it'll talk
through its reasoning and I'm sure this
is going to work
oh I'm sorry
again so working off of this did you
ever see what would happen if you
included examples like this that were
impossible and say these are not good
puzzles that's not respond to those
things like could it extrapolate like oh
these are things I don't want is I don't
know that's a great question and also I
don't know if after it generated this
puzzle if you asked it like you know if
you if you did that before or after
maybe it would generate each puzzle and
then say yeah I think this one is
good question
so I gotta admit I hate puzzles so uh on
a personal level not these kind of
puzzles but so I I was trying to
understand during so you're you're
saying solving puzzles right might uh
get us close or achieve the ability of
Chachi Kitty or these kind of models
large language models so puzzles it gets
us closer to understanding intelligence
in a way that we can quantify right
differently than with language and
answering problems
um but it's still restrictive in some
sense like we're telling what the rules
are exactly and then they're supposed to
solve it exactly and it's in in pain
we're all happy about it right so so is
there some way to give a mathematical
puzzle where it's not so obvious
obviously in the sense not that it's
okay so here's my example I suppose you
give some of your mathematical puzzles
and there's a bunch of solutions okay uh
and then you give them uh like you you
have this thing where you give also
example Solutions in order to there but
you always give it the lexographically
uh smallest solution right but you don't
tell them that's what you do you give a
solution to a puzzle who wishes a bunch
of solutions okay and for each one of
them you give them extra so there's some
hidden so there's some intelligent
there's something clever to understand
that you haven't
explicitly
spelled out what yeah
well no but it's not a puzzle puzzles is
they tell you what the rules are and you
must adhere by it oh I don't like you
don't like the NP you don't like the
things
that I can't break the rules or I can't
at least apply some personally I mean
one of the things that I'm hoping here
is like constantly what happens we we
say you know we're gonna study chess and
we're all excited we figure like when we
solve chess we must have learned
something fundamental about intelligence
and then we solve chess and you know
what it does in general right like and
then okay we did that and you know then
we did Alpha fold and they're brilliant
ideas and they do generalize to some
extent I mean I'm not saying they don't
but here again I'm optimistic like if
you were to solve these things and be
get the ability to write long correct
code
would that be useful for you to write a
novel or something like that I mean I
guess I'm just hopeful that the ability
to solve these problems as well as
humans which means sometimes writing
along correct code that is right it
involves all kinds of reasoning and
thinking that would be useful in other
domains but I admit that I'm probably
making the same mistake that every other
you know problem that eventually
succumbed and didn't generalize uh is
doing it's not really an answer to the
question I mean I specifically was
anti-what you're saying in deciding this
data set I wanted the objective to be as
clear as they
um in that way you can generate generate
your own puzzles and the rules are clear
I hate those math tests which are like
what's the next number in the sequence
and I can give you an explanation for
anything
but maybe you know but those are the
more common type of intelligence tests I
don't know
okay I think maybe only one more
question and not try the audience
patience too much I appreciate it for it
I think some kind of a local
number of tries to solve that puzzle to
define whether it's a good puzzle or not
it's one kind of reward we can have
either this little Global rewards
yes and the other thing is that whether
we can use human knowledge
alongside the line
like more
um
more kind of traditional paddles from
human and to guide the line ate it
um
yeah I mean you could that definitely
yeah all right thank you very much okay
thanks Adam
[Applause]
thank you for inviting me
I could have been there